there was a video just came out from a
california voter on the recall right now
the the recall election of gavin newsom
has two questions should the democratic
governor be recalled yes or no if
50 plus one voter says yes he should be
recalled then it goes to the second
question who
should replace him and you just answer
both so
take a listen to this woman's
description of what her ballot looks
like
make sure that you put yes
that means that yes you want gavin
newsom to lose his job
the next thing you're gonna check
is who you're going to vote for to
replace him
i am going to vote for larry elder
and his box is on the back of the page
um
i think that it is important that we
unite around one candidate but like i
said the most important thing is that we
get him out
um
this is the sketchy part this is the
crazy part
so
when you fold up your ballot
more than likely it seems natural
you're just gonna
slip this in
um but you have to pay attention to
these two holes
that are in the front of the envelope
you can see
if someone from the outside of the mail
on ballot you can see if somebody has
voted yes to recall new sim
this is so
freaking clever
it's so wrong but it's so clever so on
the mail-in ballots there are two holes
just like you took a little hole puncher
and i guess this is for sorting purposes
or i don't know i've seen them on the
envelopes before
they're two little holes right on either
side of where you sign your name to say
this is my ballot
the only question that matters on this
ballot it's just one question says
should we recall gavin newsom and it's
placed kind of bizarrely on the ballot
it's placed in kind of the middle column
a little up toward the first top half of
the page and then you saw all the way on
the right and all the way up and down
you see who should we replace them with
but the question should we or should we
not recall gavin newsom
so if you can either darken the circle
yes or darken the circle no
and just coincidentally
the circle for yes
lines up
perfectly
with the hole on the envelope
meaning
you can see
with
great a great degree of certainty from
the outside of the envelope whether or
not this ballot
is to recall gavin newsom
and you know
if that circle happens to be a little
dark i wonder you know what happens to
that ballot
does that ballot does something happen
does it disappear does it is it is there
an error with it is it
or is maybe the signature not quite
right
i don't know
of all this a very long ballot of all
the places that the only question that
matters could possibly be on that sheet
of paper front or back
it just so happens to line up perfectly
with the hole in the envelope
what are the odds
what are
the odds such
it's so typical it's it's clever but
it's typical you see things like this a
lot before and this is why we neither
trust nor like our government
this is why we want to recall the people
who are running our government
like gavin newsom glad you like that
clip the full episode is called the end
of the world as we know it you can get
it here on youtube so subscribe leave a
comment you know get that going but
what i would recommend
go to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your
podcasts
search for the michael knowles show
subscribe
thank you thank you for doing that leave
a five-star review we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]